last week tyler1 exposed some boosters
on stream now normally that kind of news
isn't too crazy but it turns out the two
suspected boosters were actually a
player and coach from a league of
legends org they have since been removed
from the team in drama which you could
describe as an absolute show
all right if you don't like boosters or
win traders in whatever game you play
then make sure you subscribe to the
score esports and like this video
because believe it or not we do make a
lot of videos like this it does happen
sadly often alright so you all know
tyler1 the reformed rager who has left
his toxic one-trick draven days behind
him to become one of the biggest league
streamers in the world and who has
reached challenger in all five roles in
the game but one thing you might not
have seen on the tyler1 bingo cards for
last week was that he became a detective
it all started with tyler and his team
not having a great game they were down
10 to 1 in kills and tyler wasn't happy
with how his jungler was playing an
evelyn player called r5 jungle
i could tell right when he mistimed his
[ __ ] ability on the camp this guy's a
[ __ ] i don't care but as the team
waited in fountain for the end of the
game tyler began to suspect something
that the evelyn on his team was win
trading with a soraka on the enemy team
a player called choco vanille and if you
don't know win trading involves one
player getting artificially boosted in
rank by a better player if the better
player is on their team they'll carry
them if they're on the enemy team
they'll throw the game and this is
exactly what tyler thought was going on
wait lately these are shared accounts
for sure
hey i didn't even notice bro she's not
gonna sleep with you bro on discord man
it's so great
tyler was accusing them of queueing up
for games separately but at the exact
same time now in high elo where the
player base is a lot smaller there's a
decent chance that two players will end
up in the same game if they do that if
win traders end up on the same team
great they've managed to dodge riot's
restriction on duo queuing in high elo
and the better player will then try hard
and carry the weaker player to victory
if they end up on opposing teams the
better player will simply throw the game
entirely the result is the same the
weaker player wins the game and
continues to get boosted in rank how
about right here r5 juggle bro
one day go r5 juggle four days ago r5
jungle bro these guys are cue sniping
each other to get on their on the same
team and when they're not on the same
team this this the e-boy runs it down
bro this is actually disgusting in fact
there were over 30 games that fit this
pattern choco vanille always seemed to
be in the same games as r5 jungle
whether as teammates or opponents if
they were teammates r5 jungle would have
a respectable score at the end of the
game and it was clear that they tried
and if they weren't r5 jungle would have
a suspicious amount of deaths and choco
vanille would most likely take home the
dub but of course if this was an
ordinary story of suspected win traders
i wouldn't be sitting here telling you
about it the next question is who were
these people in tyler's chat one user
shared a quote from liquipedia which
stated naomi choco vanille fontaine is a
league of legends esports personality
current coach and manager for imperium
van souvery an assistant coach and
manager for team ambition sussy team
ambition sussy is a north american
league of legends amateur org and yes
that is their real name
bit sussy now they're famous by no means
but just by searching for choco
vanilla's name tyler found the player's
twitter account where they'd recently
shared just how happy they were to reach
masters i don't want to like be like an
[ __ ] or call people out or anything
like that or anything you know bro but
uh we are surely
not going to our twitter and tweeting
after bits of grinding i went through
tears of joy and tilt and i have finally
like posting it on twitter we're not bro
come on
now at this point tyler1 clips were
blowing up all over the live stream
fails subreddit one commenter suggested
the r5 jungle was an account that
belonged to vincent felosa otherwise
known as anticipation the jungler for
team ambition sussy minutes after that
the general manager a team ambition
susie himself confirmed all of this on
twitter they added that choco vanille
and anticipation have been removed from
their positions effective immediately
that they do not support what they did
and that they value competitive
integrity within their org i mean
this was kind of insane in a short time
tyler1 his chat and reddit had exposed a
win trading esports player and a coach
which had resulted in them getting fired
from their jobs
crazy but if you thought the details
stopped here you'd be wrong team
ambition then tweeted out a statement in
which they confirmed the pair's removal
from the org and stated that
anticipation and choco vanille were
actually in a relationship they said
that anticipation and remember this is
r5 jungle had joined the team in january
and admitted to them that he had
previously smurfed while playing with
his girlfriend he was told of the org's
rules but was issued a warning in march
when they found signs of duo boosting on
his account he left the team for a short
time and when he returned in june as
their starting jungler choco vanille was
brought in as the manager of that roster
yeah
don't worry we'll get to that the org
said that once again they told them the
rules warned them because of their
previous behavior and asked them for the
names of all of their accounts they said
that anticipation never listed r5 jungle
as one of them they finished their
statement by acknowledging they failed
to properly vet the accounts in question
and that they understand that this whole
thing makes the amateur scene hard to
take seriously the vetting process is
definitely one thing i do sympathise
with orcs who have to check the accounts
of every last one of their players and
staff for any signs of wind trading or
boosting especially one of them just
straight up doesn't tell you about one
of their accounts also there's the fact
that team ambition had identified this
behavior in these people in the past
it's not like this came out of left
field and one thing they didn't mention
is the pretty obvious conflict of
interest when hiring someone to oversee
a team in which they're dating one of
the players and before you say oh that's
such an amateur team thing don't forget
we had a very similar load of drama when
doublelift joined tsm at a time when his
girlfriend lena was their head of
esports this kind of stuff can happen
anywhere and of course another thing
that continues to happen in the scene is
the subject of this video wind trading
i've been playing league for a
disturbingly long time and let me tell
you this has played the game since its
release granted win trading is pretty
much exclusively a high elo problem most
of the player base is below masters
meaning the vast majority of players are
allowed to duo queue in ranked unless
you're very high ranked boosters will
always use duo q to boost people in your
games which still sucks it feels like
riot sees the chance of some people
abusing duo q to boost people in games
is a small price to pay for you to be
able to grind ranked with a friend duo q
is not a perfect system and as we've
seen from this story even if you remove
it boosters will still find a way
usually by when trading even if their
jobs are on the line
there was one time when i got to diamond
where
like i kept seeing the same people in my
games diamond isn't anywhere near the
top of the rank ladder but it gets to
the point where you do occasionally
start to see the same names crop up
especially if you play a lot of games
and i was worried people people would
think i was like win trading or boosting
because like i had like the same person
like four games in a row so be careful
out there don't be
don't be false flagged that's my advice